[Music]
how on earth
did a language with tens of thousands of
characters fit onto this keyboard here
is a world of communication
tailored for your needs of today and
tomorrow what really accounts for
china's meteoric rise as a major global
power this is shenzhen it's a city in
the south of china i've actually been
there
but back in the 1980s this was just a
sleepy fishing village with less than
like 100 000 people today
it is home to 12.5 million people it's a
giant metropolis with huge buildings and
home to some of the largest tech
companies on the planet
this city is emblematic of china's
technological rise over the last 40
years it's an explosion in technology
and development that has really never
happened before in human history from an
agrarian society to a technological
powerhouse in just a couple of decades
that's vast
this almost didn't happen china almost
didn't become the technological
powerhouse
and what held them back is something i
have thought about a lot which is this
keyboard
this keyboard has like 80 or so keys and
the chinese language has like tens of
thousands of characters
so how did they fit their language onto
this keyboard to answer that question
you have to dive deep into modern china
into chairman mao
into the divide between taiwan and
mainland china who despite speaking the
same language use very different typing
methods all because of geopolitics
it's a story of how china took a
keyboard that was developed for a vastly
different language system and mastered
it mastered it better than we did here
in the west it's a fascinating story of
culture and history and technology and i
want to share with you
here is china has become a keystone of
national economic policy a large part of
china's population lives in large cities
i really don't quite understand
everything that's happening here
[Music]
to understand how chinese speakers type
on a keyboard like this
i talked to my friend mangle who
currently is in quarantine in taiwan i
just came back and currently in taiwan's
currency hotel oh my gosh wow mangle has
lived in both china and taiwan he's
technologically savvy and he helped me
understand how people type not just on
the keyboard but on their phone yeah so
basically growing up as a chinese or
taiwanese you have to learn
uh how to like write all the characters
that's kind of the thing you do first
and then you learn
like the pronunciation system behind all
the characters
and in china that's pinging and then in
taiwan let's do it so let's break this
down
most languages are written with an
alphabet
each letter in that alphabet represents
a sound and when you string those sounds
together you make a word
it seems so intuitive as if like this is
the only way to do it but in chinese
there is another way
chinese uses complex
characters for each word so every word
is a character
each one of these characters represents
a different thing an object a feeling a
concept a verb
all in all there are upwards of 70 or 80
000 of these characters this system was
just fine it worked in china for a
really long time because you could use a
brush or a pen to write stuff out i like
that it's like if it ain't broke don't
fix it
this is the qwerty keyboard it's called
the qwerty keyboard because
i mean just look at it
this is the mechanism through which
people not just communicate with each
other but code the world the software
and the programs that we all use all the
time when this started to take over
china had a real problem
listen i need to just pause to tell you
about something which is that
investing money is hard sometimes and
honestly i'm like in my 30s now and i'm
like just sort of learning the art of
investing and not really the sponsor of
today's video it's a company called
acorns
what they do is they allow you to get
started with investing with really small
amounts of money to begin with
and they make it so that you can take
your spare change from any transaction
and automatically invest it in the
background so as you go about your day
like spending money on things it
automatically invests into diversified
portfolios that are expert managed so
that you can actually start building
an investment portfolio like in the
background and without a ton of money
it's an app that allows us to all happen
very easily acorns is a financial
wellness app that makes it easy to save
and invest every day in the background
of life starting with just spare change
no expertise required
you can set up an acorns account in like
three minutes and start with just five
dollars you don't need a giant chunk of
cash to start investing and it's not
just investing you can also set up your
personal checking account and your
retirement account all in this one app
that you have access to you get this
heavy metal debit card that is the card
that when you swipe it rounds up every
transaction and invests those sense into
your portfolio you can even like get it
custom engraved so you have like a sweet
debit card that works by the way at like
tens of thousands of atm machines around
the country with no fees it's a pretty
darn good deal so there's a link in my
description it's acorns.com johnny
harris clicking that link helps support
this channel but it also gives you a 10
bonus
investment when you sign up so you can
sign up and start having 10 dollars in
your
portfolio overall i believe in starting
early with investing and acorns is a
fantastic way to get started with
minimal effort and
not a ton of money to get started but
you can just do this in the background
it's a fantastic way so thank you acorns
for sponsoring this video let's get back
to the story they had to figure out how
to fit this
onto
this
and fast because the world of computing
started to explode in the 70s and 80s
and 90s hello
i'm bill gates here in the united states
the qwerty keyboard was a very natural
tool we were able to use our alphabet
and our symbols that were all very used
to to develop programming languages so
that we could make software and soon
more and more computers were showing up
into american homes
the commodore 64 now in a home family
pack meanwhile on the other side of the
planet china a country of almost a
billion people only had 3 000 computers
in the entire country
they were so far behind the west when it
came to computer literacy the chinese
government begins to freak out and is
like guys we're getting absolutely
destroyed by the west because of this
whole computer thing and you're telling
me that it's because we can't fit our
language onto this keyboard are you
kidding me what are we gonna do about it
so the chinese government made this a
huge priority and they finally started
to develop some things that worked
got it the first major system of typing
used the qwerty keyboard to build the
shape of the characters uh we call it
and it was pretty darn complicated it's
basically like um like puzzles like like
legos
yeah kind of like a brick kind of like
you just put things together i can write
basic characters using that the system
was clever but it was complicated and
not very fast at first luckily china had
a wild card up its sleeve that would
help get chinese speakers typing on a
qwerty keyboard it had to do with this
guy chairman mao
[Applause]
the great chinese chairman mao zedong
history time here we go
the communist party propaganda machine
portrays the chairman's great leap
forward as a dazzling success mao was
really bullish about modernizing china
and one of his pet projects was
scrapping the entire chinese character
system and replacing it with a western
style alphabet that sounds out chinese
words sort of like how we sound out our
english or italian or spanish words now
was like learning thousands of chinese
characters is hard and complicated so
why don't we just have a latin romanized
alphabet like the rest of the world so
by 1949
mao was like ready to roll scrapping the
entire chinese writing system in the
name of a roman alphabet but then one of
his close buddies former communist
dictator joseph stalin convinced mao not
to totally kill off chinese characters
stalin was like dude don't do this
you're gonna regret it and mal was like
fine
so he kept the chinese characters as the
main writing system but for teaching
literacy in schools he developed a
written alphabet called pinyin
p-i-n-y-i-n
[Music]
where you can use the roman letters to
spell out chinese words by the way that
they sound okay so right now
you are typing out
this sentence in romanized characters
in the way that it would be
phonetically spelled in in roman in
like wool is w-o
right yes okay
so you type it all out
yeah and then down there it can it
renders it okay wow so now if you want
to write the word beef which is
nyorao
how to say beef i think nyoro
i've no idea instead of memorizing these
characters which means beef
you can just spell it out by the way it
sounds
this romanization of chinese again it's
called pinyin would become really
helpful years later when the chinese
government is trying to figure out how
to get their people to type on western
computers but wait a minute we can't go
on before we mention a little bit of
geopolitics
okay so it's the 1940s mao and his
communist revolutionaries are taking
over mainland china in a bloody
revolution and civil war and the chinese
government that they overthrow and are
fighting with end up losing and
retreating to an island nearby called
taiwan to continue their non-communist
version of china and they both think
that they're the real china and they
start this war that has never stopped
and they're still fighting this war and
they both think they're china and anyway
that is absolutely a story i want to
tell but i am not going there now again
blinders were talking about qwerty
keyboards really trying to figure
something out we need to focus okay so
you have these two chinas the communist
one the non-communist one mao is pushing
the romanized alphabet in the communist
version of china and taiwan is like
no this romanized pinyin thing is an
invention of the communist party and a
total sellout of the chinese traditional
writing system no way but taiwan is
secretly like we love the idea of having
an alphabet for our chinese language
because it makes it a lot easier to
teach literacy so they adopt an alphabet
but it's not the pinyin romanized
alphabet it is an old alphabetic system
that was developed in the early 1900s
it's doing
they did it before pinging they
completely newly invented this set of
symbols
for this purpose
wow that is wild so because they hated
their communist enemies taiwan rejected
the romanized alphabet that mao was
pushing and stuck with this traditional
alphabet that had been developed a few
years earlier
and that's still how it is today
[Music]
so this gets to a pretty satisfying
answer to the question of this entire
video which is how do chinese speakers
type on a qwerty keyboard the answer is
if you go to mainland china you're going
to see keyboards like this
people in mainland china use this
keyboard to type out the sounds of their
words and then the computer takes that
and renders it into chinese characters
if you live in taiwan
you'll see a keyboard that looks more
like this but you basically do the same
thing you use these characters to type
out the sounds of the word and the
computer will render it into a chinese
character
both of these are new writing systems
that were developed in the past 100
years to help chinese speakers spell out
their words and move away from a
character-based system what are the key
features that you think should be in the
ideal laptop standby for the software
transmission you better start your
recorders now okay back to our timeline
here it's the 80s and 90s china is
starting to really adopt technology and
they're using these typing methods
to use the qwerty keyboard to actually
participate in the computing world but
they are still lacking so far behind the
western world they're way slower in
their typing so the chinese government
went back to the drawing boards and was
like how can we make it faster and boy
did they find a solution in the 80s that
would change everything
[Music]
and this is where it gets kind of juicy
in my opinion like this is the part that
like
i don't know really helps me understand
how people type today
you know when you go to google and you
start typing a sentence and it like
fills out the rest of the sentence for
you or even on gmail these days like
i'll be typing and suddenly it'll like
predict what i want to say
it's pretty cool it's not life-changing
it sort of like saves me maybe a couple
milliseconds every day in china
this technology of predictive text and
predictive typing
was life-changing because regardless of
what method you use to start building
your characters in the computer the
computer now starts to guess what
characters you want to type for example
let's say someone is using one of these
systems the one where you build
characters and they type this character
this is the root of a chinese word and
it means water the computer sees this
and says okay you just typed water
there's a bunch of characters that are
derived from this root this water root
for example here's the one for river or
maybe you actually want this one which
is the word for wash so if you just type
water
you can look at these options and decide
which one you want this was an
algorithmic predictive typing system
that was happening in the late 1980s in
china three whole decades before
anything similar surfaced in the west
and it is this technology of predictive
text
that changed everything for china before
computers there was no practical way to
type the thousands of characters called
kanji to deal with the complexity of
these symbol words different systems
have been adopted
they started to refine this algorithm to
make it more and more clear that as soon
as you start typing anything the
algorithm says do you want to do this or
this or this or this
i mean i have been watching a great deal
of
of competitions typing competitions
this is a thing in china and if you zoom
in and look closely at these
competitions you'll see that as soon as
these competitors start typing a pop-up
box comes up giving them an
algorithmically generated menu of
options that predicts
what they are trying to type
so typing in chinese is as much about
choosing from this predictive menu as it
is about pressing the keys it is a
combination of both and this competition
has pushed developers to make better and
better predictive algorithms so that
people can communicate very efficiently
using the keyboard so how fast are these
people typing right now well the average
english speaker can type at around 43
words per minute i work on a computer
all day so i'm probably more like 60 65
words per minute there is an english
typing competition in las vegas and the
type is here are a mind blowing 163
words per minute but if you head back to
these guys
these people are typing at a score of
242
words per minute
[Music]
four times faster than i can type
and almost double what they're typing in
english at the best competition in las
vegas
whoa wow that's fast yeah it's fast so
china used this technology that was
developed in the west mainly designed
for languages that are very different
than chinese
and they mastered it but guess what the
chinese government
still has the need for speed they're
like how can we make it faster
so predictive typing in china went from
letting you start a character
and predicting what character you want
to choose to then going to
seeing what character you just put and
predicting the next one the next word in
the sentence that you want to say
and now in the last few years they are
pushing it to the next level which is
cloud-based predictive texting
again the closest thing we have to this
in the west is like the google
auto-complete you go to the search
engine you start typing and the internet
is like a lot of people are searching
this so we think you're searching this
too but imagine instead of just a search
engine
imagine if this concept were everywhere
as you're typing your word document
as you're texting your mom
anywhere in the digital space that is
connected to the internet is now feeding
you
sentences that they think maybe you want
to say based on an ai generated web of
information of what everyone else is
texting and emailing and writing
so an example of this is let's say
there's a chinese movie star that just
got in a big car accident it's all over
the news and everybody's talking about
it you've never typed this movie star's
name before but as soon as you do start
typing it your phone starts talking to
the cloud and not just the internet but
other people's text messages so then the
algorithm says i think that you probably
want to text about this movie star and
their car accident and this seems like a
great time saving technology that helps
chinese speakers type it's a great idea
but just imagine some scenarios here
let's say that you're not writing about
a movie star in a car accident but let's
say instead you're texting a friend
about june 4th 1989
tiananmen square
the noise of gunfire rose from all over
the center of peking china
is a nation at war with itself there's
one major company that owns the software
this one company determines most of what
shows up in predictive text and in a
country where there's not a lot of
hesitation to control citizens access to
information it's not a far stretch to
see how subtle manipulation could start
to occur with this cloud predictive text
now there's an algorithm deciding sort
of what should go next
for example if you type in taiwan is
china
the algorithm will suggest to you
taiwan is an inseparable
part of china anyway this is not a major
problem right now and i'm not saying
that the government is
manipulating every individual in china
with predictive text all i'm saying is
that the story of how chinese speakers
have been able to type on the qwerty
keyboard
is the story of really clever and
amazing technological advancements and a
huge part of that has been predictive
algorithms
and all i'm saying is that
algorithmically presented information
can lead to some dangerous outcomes in
terms of making people think a certain
way but at the end of the day let us
just end on the fact that china has
developed a really amazing technology
for getting their language into the
computer
and by doing so have been able to pass
up any typists in the west
helping fuel the rise of china as a
technological powerhouse
that's the story here and
i really learned a lot thank you all for
watching i will see you soon and thanks
for being here